mein Vater hat mir gesagt ich soll
Traktorfahrer werden Scheiße bin ich
aber nicht ich bin Soldat geworden
dieser Aufnahmen sollen aus Belgorod
stammen angeblich kämpfen gleich zwei
russische Gruppierungen in Russland um
die Ukraine zu unterstützen und Putin zu
stürzen
wir wollen dass unsere Kinder in Frieden
aufwachsen um reisen um studieren zu
können und einfach glücklich zu sein in
einem freien Land aber dafür gibt es
keinen Platz in Putins Russland das
verrottet ist durch Korruption Lügen
Zensur Einschränkungen und Unterdrückung
ja von beiden Organisationen hat man
schon in der Vergangenheit gehört es gab
entgleiste Züge es gab Anschläge
Anschläge auf
Bahnschienen auf Gleisanlagen in der in
Russland und es sind auch immer wieder
Züge entgleist also das scheint hinter
den Kulissen in Russland eine Art
gewaltsame Widerstandsbewegung zu
operieren
acht Menschen sollen in der
westrorischen Region Belgorod bei den
Anschlägen verletzt worden sein diese
Bilder sollen Evakuierungen zeigen ob
sie echt sind kann nicht mit Sicherheit
gesagt werden
während Russland ukrainische
sabotagegruppen für die Anschläge
verantwortlich macht weist selenskis
Berater podoljak die Verantwortung
seines Landes für die Anschläge schon
fast genüsslich zurück die Ukraine
beobachtet die Vorkommnisse in Belgorod
mit Interesse und studiert die Situation
hat aber nichts damit zu tun
es geht aus meiner Sicht in erster Linie
darum Verwirrung zu stiften und Russland
zu blamieren und wenn man sich die
Bilder der letzten beiden Tage anguckt
dann ist das eindeutig auch gelungen das
ist sehr peinlich für Russland was da
passiert ein weiteres Ziel liegt auf der
Hand russische Streitkräfte von der
Kriegsfront abzuziehen um ihre Heimat zu
verteidigen dieser Plan ist heute
aufgegangen